[Music]
the fundamental root of itall building
block for linear algebra is the vector
so it's worth making sure that we're all
on the same page about what exactly a
vector is you see broadly speaking there
are three distinct but related ideas
about vectors which I'll call the
physics student perspective the computer
science student perspective and the
mathematicians perspective
the physics student perspective is that
vectors are arrows pointing in space
what defines a given Vector is its
length and the direction its pointing
but as long as those two facts are the
same you can move it all around and it's
still the same Vector vectors that live
in the flat plane are two-dimensional
and those sitting in broader space that
you and I live in are
three-dimensional the computer science
perspective is that vectors are ordered
lists of numbers for example let's say
you were doing some analytics about
house prices and the only features you
cared about were square footage and
price you might model each house with a
pair of numbers the first indicating
square footage and the second indicating
price notice the order matters
here in the lingo you'd be modeling
houses as two-dimensional vectors where
in this context Vector is pretty much
just a fancy word for list and what
makes it two-dimensional is the fact
that the length of that list is
two the mathematician on the other hand
seeks to generalize both these views
basically saying that a vector can be
anything where there's a sensible notion
of adding two vectors and multiplying a
vector by a number operations that I'll
talk about later on in this video the
details of this view are rather abstract
and I actually think it's healthy to
ignore it until the last video of this
series favoring a more concrete setting
in the interim but the reason I bring it
up here is that it hints at the fact
that the ideas of vector addition and
multiplication by numbers will play an
important role throughout linear algebra
but before I talk about those operations
let's just settle in on a specific
thought to have in mind when I say the
word Vector given the geometric Focus
that I'm shooting for here whenever I
introduce a new topic involving vectors
I want you to First think about an arrow
and specifically think about that Arrow
inside a coordinate system like the XY
plane with its tail sitting at the
origin this is a little bit different
from the physics student perspective
where vectors can freely sit anywhere
they want in space in linear algebra
it's almost always the case that your
vector will be rooted at the order
then once you understand A New Concept
in the context of arrows in space we'll
translate it over to the list of numbers
point of view which we can do by
considering the coordinates of the
vector now while I'm sure that many of
you are already familiar with this
coordinate system it's worth walking
through explicitly since this is where
all of the important back and forth
happens between the two perspectives of
linear algebra focusing our attention on
two dimensions for the moment you have a
horizontal line called the x-axis and a
vertical line called the y-axis the
place where they intersect is called the
origin which you should think of as the
center of space and the root of all
vectors after choosing an arbitrary
length to represent one you make tick
marks on each axis to represent this
distance when I want to convey the idea
of 2D space as a whole which you'll see
comes up a lot in these videos I'll
extend these tick marks to make grid
lines but right now they'll actually get
a little bit in the way the coordinates
of a vector is a pair of numbers that
basically gives instructions for how to
get from the tail of that Vector at the
origin to its tip
the first number tells you how far to
walk along the x-axis positive numbers
indicating rightward motion negative
numbers indicating leftward motion and
the second number tells you how far to
walk parallel to the y- AIS after that
positive numbers indicating upward
motion and negative numbers indicating
downward motion to distinguish vectors
from points the convention is to write
this pair of numbers vertically with
square brackets around
them every pair of numbers gives you one
and only one vector and every Vector is
associated with one and only one pair of
numbers what about in three dimensions
well you add a third axis called the
z-axis which is perpendicular to both
the X and Y AIS and in this case each
Vector is associated with an ordered
triplet of numbers the first tells you
how far to move along the x-axis the
second tells you how far to move
parallel to the y- AIS and the third one
tells you how far to then move parallel
to this new Z axis every triplet of
numbers gives you one unique Vector in
space and every Vector in space gives
you exactly one triplet of
numbers all right so back to vector
addition and multiplication by numbers
after all every topic in linear algebra
is going to center around these two
operations luckily each one's pretty
straightforward to Define let's say we
have two vectors one pointing up and a
little to the right and the other one
pointing right and down a bit to add
these two vectors move the second one so
that its tail sits at the tip of the
first one then if you draw a new Vector
from the tail of the first one to where
the tip of the second one now sits that
new Vector is their
Su this definition of addition by the
way is pretty much the only time in
linear algebra where we let vectors
stray away from the origin now why is
this a reasonable thing to do why this
definition of addition and not some
other
one well the way I like to think about
it is that each Vector represents a
certain movement a step with a certain
distance and direction in
space if you take a step along the first
Vector then take a step in the direction
and distance described by the second
Vector the overall effect is just the
same as if you moved along the sum of
those two vectors to start with you
could think about this as an extension
of how we think about adding numbers on
a number line one way that we teach kids
to think about this say with 2 + 5 is to
think of moving two steps to the right
followed by another five steps to the
right the overall effect is the same as
if you just took seven steps to the
right in fact let's see how vector
addition looks numerically the first
Vector here has coordinates one
2 and the second one has coordinates
31 when you take the vector sum using
this tip toil method you can think of a
four-step path from the origin to the
tip of the second Vector walk one to the
right then two up then three to the
right then one down reorganizing these
steps so that you first do all of the
right word motion then do all the
vertical motion you can read it as
saying first move 1 + 3 to the right
then move 2 - 1
up so the new Vector has coordinates 1 +
3 and 2
+1 in general vector addition in this
list of numbers conception looks like
matching up their terms and adding each
one
together the other fundamental Vector
operation is multiplication by a number
now this is best understood just by
looking at a few examples if you take
the number two and multiply it by a
given Vector it means you stretch out
that Vector so that it's two times as
long as when you started if you multiply
that vector by say 1/3 it means you
squish it down so that it's 1/3 the
original length when you multiply it by
a negative number like - 1.8 then the
vector first gets flipped around then
stretched out by that factor of
1.8 this process of stretching or
squishing or sometimes vering the
direction of a vector is called scaling
and whenever you catch a number like 2
or 1/3 or 1.8 acting like this scaling
some Vector you call it a scaler in fact
throughout linear algebra one of the
main things that numbers do is scale
vectors so it's common to use the word
scaler pretty much interchangeably with
the word number numerically stretching
out a vector by a factor of say two
corresponds with multiplying each of its
components by that factor two so in the
conception of vectors as lists of
numbers multiplying a given vector by a
scaler means multiplying each one of
those components by that
scalar you'll see in the following
videos what I mean when I say that
linear algebra topics tend to revolve
around these two fundamental operations
vector addition and scalar
multiplication and I'll talk more in the
last video about how and why the
mathematician thinks only about these
operations independent and abstracted
away from however you choose to
represent vectors in truth it doesn't
matter whether you think about vectors
as fundamentally being arrows in space
like I'm suggesting you do that happen
to have a nice numerical representation
or fundamentally as lists of numbers
that happen to have a nice geometric
interpretation the usefulness of linear
algebra has less to do with either one
of these views than it does with the
ability to translate back and forth
between them it gives the data analyst a
nice way to conceptualize many lists of
numbers in a visual way which can
seriously clarify patterns in data and
give a global view of what certain
operations do do and on the flip side it
gives people like physicists and
computer Graphics programmers a language
to describe space and the manipulation
of space using numbers that can be
crunched and run through a computer when
I do mathy animations for example I
start by thinking about what's actually
going on in space and then get the
computer to represent things numerically
thereby figuring out where to place the
pixels on the screen and doing that
usually relies on a lot of linear
algebra
understanding so there are your vector
Basics and in the next video video I'll
start getting into some pretty neat
Concepts surrounding vectors like span
bases and linear dependence see you then
[Music]